s
Radio-Canada et je suis heureux
de vous faire découvrir arrière
Roy.
♪ Tous les chemins
qu'elle arpente ♪
♪ Se perdent sur mes os ♪
- Ariane Roy, retenez bien
ce nom, c'est la nouvelle
Révélation Radio-Canada
dans la catégorie chanson.
♪ Je me promène ♪
♪ J'aime regarder ♪
Ariane, j'étais tellement
content quand j'ai appris que
c'était toi la Révélation Radio-
Canada, parce que tu es une
des artistes que j'ai le plus
écoutés de l'année 2021
puis c'est un EP que t'avais
lancé dans des circonstances
particulières.
ARIANE ROY, auteur-compositrice-
interprète, Révélation R.-C.
- Oui. J'ai lancé le EP
le 6 mars, donc c'est vraiment
la... une semaine de la tombée
de la pandémie avant que
tout s'écroule. Fait que
c'était un drôle de timing, mais
bizarrement, je considère quand
même que j'ai été chanceuse.
- C'est que l'artiste de 24 ans
a eu une année bien chargée.
Elle a participé au concours
Destination Chanson fleuve
au Festival de la chanson
de Petite-Vallée.
♪ ♪ ♪
Au Festival international
de la chanson de Granby.
♪ Le ciel ne tombe plus ♪
Et aussi aux Francouvertes.
♪ De cette mascarade futile ♪
Le talent d'Ariane Roy
a été remarqué et salué.
Et c'est maintenant au tour
de Radio-Canada de soutenir
sa carrière durant un an
sur toutes ses plateformes.
CATHERINE POGONAT
- On peut applaudir Ariane Roy,
notre nouvelle Révélation
chanson Radio-Canada!
- Les Révélations Radio-Canada
existent depuis 2008.
Une soixantaine d'artistes
ont reçu cet honneur
et pas les moindres.
Émile Bilodeau, Hubert Lenoir
et Coeur de Pirate ont reçu
ce coup de pouce en début
de carrière.
- Félicitations,
Coeur de Pirate!
COEUR DE PIRATE
auteur-compositrice-interprète
- Sauf que quand t'as Radio-Can
qui est derrière toi, c'est
excellent, là. Fait que, oui,
moi, ça m'a vraiment aidée.
Puis c'était une grosse affaire
à l'époque puis ça l'est
encore aujourd'hui.
- Ça donne le goût d'être
à la hauteur aussi, tu te dis :
OK, là, il y a ça, je peux pas
arriver à moitié,
faut que ça soit solide,
faut que ça soit travaillé.
- Les autres lauréats de la
cuvée 2021 sont Joyce N'Sana
dans la catégorie musique
métissée, le quatuor mené
par Julien Fillion en jazz,
la rappeuse Calamine et la
violoniste passionnée de musique
ancienne Marie Nadeau-Tremblay,
des révélations à découvrir
pour l'amour de la musique.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.